o exame não tá a gravar eu estou lá
então estão em bom estado o lado pessoal
e quem fala é o dark sejam muito bem
então isso é nice amb para falar assim é
mais um vídeo e eu estraguei que dj é o
cr ou seja a verba que mostrou jogar
sujo do evernote ajuda aí você já
apoiaram pra [ __ ] e os gamers 10.3 e
agora nós estamos na versão 10.5 fixa ou
seja a taxa fixa que tem aqui uma coisa
muito interessante que é história
envolve que a história eu tô aqui no ar
para caraças porque eu não quero jogar
isso mas não tem que ser né tem que ser
tem de ser para lá
aqui vocês podem perguntar para excluir
o fred dá pra escolher o boni vamos lá
ver o pólen o professor
o pessoal indo aos clientes já o
newell's muitos têmos muitos também está
tudo escuro neste domingo ó weissman
ignatti bonita e agora jogar num quero
ficar ok pessoal só estamos eu já começa
tudo muito silencioso outra coisa
pessoal eu vou tentar não dar muitos
cortes neste vídeo porque eu sei que
muitos de vocês gostam de ver os vídeos
sem cortes cortes né e então não vamos
cortar agora lagarto diz que se tudo
seguir é como o pantera
ontem lá
o objetivo é ganhar cinco objetos em um
minuto
o objetivo em um minuto pois é isso
o objetivo é um objeto será um objeto
não final e não funciona ana cinco
objetos o que é que deve haver qualquer
coisa agora eu percebi então um modo
história é que pus lenda que em vez de
oito páginas cinco objetos mas com tempo
não é tão divertido
agora eu gostaria de saber é o que eu
tenho de apanhar a que a herança é ok
afinal o espírito que ela vai ter alguns
cortes porque vou dar aqui bull é a dor
né
a procura das coisas aí o planeta também
houve operação urbana
o objeto foi lançado como assim
já passou o tempo aí eu não podia o
objetivo agora é ayew não culpado e já o
louco aqui né ai ai
houve um palhaço houve fred isso eu acho
que o fred
aí o michel nele isso é sempre boa e com
isso é para mim o meu rouco venceu o meu
computador achado no ok ok e estuprar
pesado está muito pesado este jogo mas
vamos lá continuar não sei que o
objetivo que opõe à ok não isso não
funciona a é isso que será esta funciona
como assim o queira objetos não caí aqui
deve ter algum bicho aí eu tô aqui
perguntando se aquilo que o objeto
campanha da [ __ ] com um objeto em um
objeto solo já sem os jogos justificou a
brilhar área e os objetos que eu tenho
que ganhar é isso mas vamos falar agora
muita concentração ok eu preciso apagar
a luz na ong acha preciso acender o ano
é e depois é pagá lá é que para
conseguir ver
não isso não resulta no resultado
funciona a baixo não é por isso que o be
não vai apanhar não é que tem que ser
aqui no meu certo ponto 1 dolby surround
esquerda por isso vamos direto enganou
neto fudido agora não é opção
instalando lá lá é fácil dar que parece
difícil mas é fácil vai embora
ok object object era linda trás
op pessoal para lá outra vez jantará dar
aquela dor de cabeça que já fui a sério
este jogo é muito pesado o tac o mapa
ela não conseguir sem luz e como também
no a a folha existe um mapa aqui dentro
do cérebro anda lá ok deve ter um objeto
em um objeto que defender não tem
maravilha que maravilha e adoro assim
jogos nos metem objetivos objetivos
impossíveis que não dá pra encarar fumar
vocês viram agora andar e do estudo
mesmo é que eu vou jogar isto eu não sei
lá mais uma vez de apanhar objetos que
não existem e aeiou cair muita
concentração agora pessoal pessoal só
vamos lá vamos pensar pensar valor
recorde de campanha ao gent momento da
gente pensar em mais nada lá ok aqui tem
um jeito não tem nada e armários brasil
sério escreveu o objeto não é não é
objeto de lá anda lá não é por aí a
outro lado os fãs para provar o posto à
prova e isso muito bem o que embora os
garis nos comentários
eu preciso ver que eu preciso de dicas
op um objeto ou caixas faltam quatro mas
temos tempo do estudo já já fui eu já
falei ai ai agora
agora olha que o objeto não está só um
livro que é uma tranche pé o silencioso
agora que acabou o tempo em que adotou
conseguir apanhar os objetos por aqui
outro objeto phone
agora é que eu consegui apanhar os
objetos todos aqui perto
será que ainda consigo um passar o
objetivo é o meu corpo nem se usa o pai
dele
ora meu companheiro dentro do susto não
tá tudo bem tá linda flor não disputará
está tudo é muito burro adora será
fechado ao público
pagamos para os eu quero junto pedro
custos fixos da trave
não imaginam jogo não não jogo não jogo
ok pessoal eu não sei se ele vai ficar
pequeno ou muito longo e não sai mas é
isso essa foi minha perspetiva que na
atualização do joystick preenchem um
software finais só que existiam foram
então é isso pessoal quanto ao
comentário lá embaixo e cliquei mas o
jogo ainda estava a rodar por seu bom
nome mas tá deixando o facto brito fica
mais é a próxima grande